we have any Baseball fans
here all right our next speaker is an
Umpire in the McLean Little
League please welcome
John morning
everyone uh thanks for having me uh glad
to be in this room uh I teach uh at the
McDonald School some data visualization
here and I never get to go in the big
room I always have to be in the small
classroom so I'm glad to be here and I'm
excited for you all and for us to learn
about R and data visualization and all
the great stuff that you can do with
data viz over the next day and a half or
so um but I want to talk about some of
the bad stuff that we do so this is just
GNA kind of be a fun fun 20 minutes so
just sit back and relax um you know one
of the things that we learn in data
visualization is that there are great
ways to communicate data to help people
understand information and Analysis and
data but there's also bad ways to do it
and so we can start by just
recognizing is that the first rule of
data visualization is that there are no
rules to data visualization which is
what a lot of us try to say but it's
really not true because the really is
just one rule for data visualization
which is anybody know what the one rule
is yeah bar chart should start at zero
okay so that's really the that's like
the one rule we can all agree on now
like are there ruu other rules to data
visualization sure like should pie
charts sum to 100% like yeah they should
sum to 100% is that a rule I don't know
just like I for me that's just like
common sense I don't really call that a
rule but like you know people do stuff
like this all the time they start their
bar charts other than zero and then they
totally distort the data uh this is some
con some Congressional candidate in
Georgia but L you think I'm gonna be
biased today against the Republicans
don't worry the Democrats do the same
thing uh Andrew Yang did this too like
22 and a half percent is that not that
much bigger than 21% only if you start
to access to something other than zero
so you can really you know ex uh uh
distort all the data but aside from that
the second rule of data visualization is
that there are no rules to data
visualization right data Vis at its core
is the intersection of Art and Science
right underlying it is data and yet we
have lots of ways that we can add design
and we can be creative and we
communicate our data in engaging ways to
help people understand information
understand analysis engage them help
them find insights and help find
discoveries but there is also the bad
stuff and the bad stuff can be
subjective we don't like certain colors
we don't like a certain layout we don't
like a certain graph but can also be
objective where people are just liars
right and they're misinforming us and
they're deceiving us and they're lying
to us and that's where our
responsibility comes in because as
people working in data and working in
data VI we need to be the responsible
party we need to be able to come out and
say hey this person is lying to us okay
so there's the fun side of this that
we'll start with and then there's the
serious side of this that says hey we
have a responsibility people who know
how to work with data and make data viiz
to do a better job so I am going to
propose that we have a data
visualization Hall of Shame okay and the
data visualization Hall of Shame can be
a mixture of these things and I'm going
to suggest that when you get inducted
into the data Vis Hall of Shame you get
a particular award I'm going to call it
the
Tucky you're awarded a toughy when you
get into the datais Hall of Shame now
not every bad visualization deserves a
tuy okay so I'm going to reserve those
to the really egregious ones from my
view it's really the ones that are
misleading uh and are distorting the
data and are lying to us but you'll see
a few in here where I think just just
because they're so egregiously bad they
just deserve their own toughy now I'm
not going to excuse myself this is my
visualization from uh an article I
published back in like 2010 2009
something like that this three 3D line
garbage terribleness right like just the
3D stuff is generally terrible so so I'm
not going to induct myself and I'm not
going to give myself a toughy but still
like we all have the skeletons in our
closets okay so I'm gonna break these
into some different categories so first
we're to start with the Hall of Shame of
colors um I don't
think I don't think you need an MFA
design to know that this is terrible
I'll also say by the way that uh I'll
have a QR code at the end where you can
grab the deck and you can go have as
much fun as you want with with with
these okay so um but you don't need an
MFA in design to know this is terrible
is this egregiously bad like no someone
just like pick like as many different
colors and and patterns as they could
find but like it's not trying to lie to
us now this one this is from the
National Weather Service okay they
should know better okay this is like
life and death stuff of a major storm in
New England so I'm going to give this
one a tough te um but you know I don't
think they're trying to lie they're just
like not doing it well right they should
just listen to Hadley and just do what
Hadley says and then we'll all just be
better off I feel like I can say hadly
here and everybody in this room is like
yep okay we got that all right we're
good okay this this is another example a
lot of great examples coming out of coid
um this is uh coid rates uh in
Washington state not particularly
helpful when the rates go up and you
don't change your color palette um so as
just as a reference Point Ben Jones uh
created this map of the same data that's
in grayscale but you can see like there
is some variation here right and you
can't really do that if you just make
everything red uh doesn't really help
okay so the punching bag of data
visualization are pie charts so of
course everybody loves to make fun of
pie charts because you see garbage like
this all the time Fox is a great
infinite resource of bad data
visualization people love to make fun of
3D exploding pie charts they don't sum
them more than 100% these are of course
great um actually this one is a is a
prime example right
like like yes High chart should sum to
100% is that a rule or just like common
sense I don't know you you decide but
like more fundamentally than that the
labels should match the slices and the
pie charts but even more fundamentally
than that right the answer to the
question of what was the best part of
the Super Bowl is not yet yes or no it's
just not okay so more fundamentally um
this is not a pie chart but still part
to hole and I just love let's just look
at what's going on in this shirt we have
70%
polyester 30% pu whatever that is
56% polyester 44% viscous which little
concerning and then 100% polyester so I
don't know what is in this shirt but
just be careful when you put it on this
is my personal favorite favorite pie
chart okay and it's not
because it's not because an an exploding
pie chart it's not because it sums some
more than 100% it's not because it shows
change over time all of which are very
strange decisions my favorite part of
this pie chart is the data source
because the data source is listed as a
margin of
error which is just delightful that you
would do that okay here's another one
another coid one now this is kind of
like an exploding pie chart this is
showing different contagion rates across
different disease types notice coid 19
the
4.12% contagion rate It's always
important to read the fine print
especially when it's put in a big red
box let's take a look the numbers for
coid 19 Co 19 remain a rough estimate
because the long incubation period means
that we still have no idea how many
people have been infected so why are we
making graphs when we have no idea
what's going on so this one gets a
toughy in my opinion all right so we
start with pies we can go to pairs of
Pies um this is a great one this is
showing okay so like pie charts of the
distribution of of people in this
University male female International and
urm whatever that is but like you know I
I like the non-binary moving beyond the
binary but I still think International
students do have a gender
um I'll give you a second to try to
understand this pair of pie charts I'm
going to give you five seconds to just
try to read this pair of pie
chart don't break your brain okay if
you're having trouble I'll draw it out
for you so the orange slice on the left
is the green Slice on the right the
green Slice on the left is a yellow
Slice on the right the blue slice is
match and then the yellow slice is the
orange slice so don't hurt yourself I'll
keep clicking but like just pairs of
pies and then of course if you're going
to do pairs might as well just do more
and more pie charts right and just give
it everybody a Time series and series of
pie charts right so again just pie
charts are fun to make fun of because
they are pie charts but there're I could
get into why I think you can make pie
charts but we're not gonna we're not
going to get there okay the inverted
axis so this is probably the most famous
and best example of the inverted axis so
for those of you who uh well I don't
know uh well some people may not have
been born when this came out at this
point like I feel that's how old I'm
getting at this point um this is a a
fairly fake famous example from the
South China Morning Post of using an
inverted axis so this is showing deaths
in Iraq the lighter red color are
civilian deaths the darker red color are
um Coalition deaths from the military
and what we have is data going from 2003
to 2011 and then the positive axis is
actually flipped here so it goes from
zero at the top to 1500 at the bottom
and so this is just a great graphic
right because you got this kind of
rounded bar chart it's got the red color
looks like dripping blood it's bloody
toll at the top it's a great graphic
from the data Vis design perspective not
from the actual content right just a
just a great way to to to evoke uh
emotions with data and then someone down
the hall a couple years later from from
the person who created this someone down
the hall created tried another similar
type of visualization and they tried to
show gun deaths in Florida right and
again it's using this inverted axis
starting in 1990 going to 2012 and zero
at the top but 1,00 at the bottom and of
course here when you look at this it
totally changes our perspective the day
right here when we look at this I'll
just I'll just ask what do you think is
encoding the data when you just look at
it immediately what is encoding the
data the line right yeah so why does
this not work right because it's that
black that dark black line that outlines
the red area and there's the axis at the
bottom rather at the top all these
things make us think that the data is
actually the line but it's not right
it's actually if you flip this whole
thing around it's actually this is the
pattern and so these inverted axes still
going from 1990 now going up from 0 to
these inverted axes are a great way to
distort and mislead people now this
person of course in the old days when
Twitter was a thing the author of this
piece just got destroyed on Twitter but
she was trying right she was just trying
something different but then you see
people trying this to misinform this is
from Pike County and Kentucky during the
early couple months of the pandemic
right wow coid infections in our County
are going down well yeah sure if you
flip the axis right but like what the
hell it's actually going up because when
you go up from 0 to 40 so they updated
this if you notice I'm going to go back
notice it's from 0 to 35 because the end
point here is June 8th and people were
like what the hell what are you doing
people they were like the next week they
were like oh yeah so June 11th they were
like oh yeah we should probably like
actually make this make this true right
okay so lots of ways to destroy with
this one gets a this one definitely gets
a tough de okay and then there's a whole
class of data visualizations that get
their own space in the Hall of shame
that just don't understand how numbers
work okay so for this one like let's
just all agree that
336 is not greater than 336 it's not
greater than 336 and it's not greater
than 336 like that's not how numbers
work okay um also like
133% is not greater than 25% and 28% is
not zero like what the hell man this is
not how numbers work okay this is this
is from the this is from the economic
times like this is a fairly reputable
thing now this is this is very early
remember early on the days we're all
concerned about is is the is the is the
virus like on our our cereal boxes right
like this was a thing you remember like
wiping down cereal boxes at the
beginning so they looked at how long
does it remain viable on certain
Services cardboard that first bar there
24 hours plastic and stainless steel
three days I don't know about you but
you can't put days and hours on the same
axis it's just not right like this is
what the bars the bars go all the way
out here people we can't just be making
stuff up and putting things on the same
axis that one to me gets a tough de and
then there's labels labels are just like
this is just unbelievable now I don't
think they're trying to mislead here I
think they just like let's just make a
map because everybody loves maps and
let's just label everything on the map I
I'll give this a tpd only because it
just hurts my like artistic
sensibilities it's just painful to look
at um this one I don't think it's a
toughy but I just I just still can't get
my head around what's going on with the
y axis here like zero 11 22 33 you're
like okay I get it you're going up by
11s that's kind of a strange OH 43 no
okay 50 okay so I don't know what's
going on in this one right okay this is
one of my also one of my favorites we've
talked about 3D a little bit already 3D
is is uh clearly distorts the data look
at the certification bar this is from
from the USDA Department of Agriculture
loves 3D I don't know what's going on
there something in the water over there
they love 3D they love clip art take a
look at that certification bar it's
labeled 1833 and yet no part of that bar
actually touches the 1800 grid line
right we all know this this is the
Distortion that's caused by 3D that's
not my favorite part of this graph my
favorite part of this graph is the y
axis label over on the side the yaxis
label is millions slash billions so it's
a Choose Your Own Adventure of
administrative cost how much do you want
to
spend uh You' probably seen this one
this one was uh from a couple of months
ago showing uncertainty showing error
bars is great let's zoom in on these
error bars and see how much errors is
actually uh shown here oh wait it's just
the letter
t uh this paper was actually retracted
um because yeah because of the letter T
okay that could certainly gets a tough
de and then there are ones that just
hella funny man I mean if you're going
to make a vend diagram or something that
even looks like a vend
diagram like seriously just be very
careful right like you don't want to
work for this company okay I'll let you
enjoy this
one like we all know we should be
careful with our use of icons because of
how we represent people but like if
you're not showing decapitations maybe
don't decapitate your icons um okay this
is one of my favorites okay this is a
real old one all right I'm going to show
you what the segments are in a second
but first F I'll ask you instead of I'll
just ask you what's the first thing you
observe about this I'm gonna give you
the title top 10 drunkest cities in
America what's the first thing you
observe
here how many cities are
there there are nine cities on the graph
of the top 10 drunkest cities in America
now let's look at what we're going to
plot on this graph so the first segment
the green segment as the bottom the
percent of excessive drinkers in each
City that makes sense sounds good the
red segment is the percent of alcohol
involved driving deaths in each City
that makes sense that seems like a a
metric let's at the yellow segment is
the number of bars and
restaurants and if that was an enough
meaning for you let's layer on top of
that the median household
income so okay so there you go like the
best labeled graph ever okay and then
there are people who are just they're
just lying to us man and again this is
our responsibility right so this is from
the Council of economic advisors under
the Trump administration at the very be
sort of towards the beginning of the
pandemic you could see what's happening
and you could see what's happening in
the number of infections around the
world and you know that the data
collection is Irregular at that point
and so what do they do they fit some
weird cubic model of just the time
series to show don't worry it's just
going to go down in a couple of weeks
don't worry about it so these guys are
just liars they get a big red toughy as
far as I'm concerned for this one um I
don't know who this who this person is
but the Tweet was or the Tik Tok was if
you want to know why people have lost
faith faith in capitalism this might
help this is showing rental prices
increasing by 160% between 1985 and the
end of 2023 as compared to median
household income that had only increased
by
40% yeah sure if you only inflate one of
them you get this totally different time
series right but when you use the
inflation adjustment on both series they
don't look that different and thanks to
Philip pump at the post who actually did
a nice piece on this right so this guy
gets a red tck te right and so again
this is our responsibility one more this
one just infuriates me this is from the
Florida standard uh uh news media
organization in Florida talking about um
children uh in the Medicaid Program who
are uh receiving uh puberty care or
gender affirming care the article says
I'll just read this aloud from 2017 to
2021 there was an increase in children
as young as 16 who received irreversible
surgical procedures in the Medicaid
population between 17 and 20 only three
children underwent such procedures but
in 2022 2021 alone the number was 12
children which represents an 1100 per
increase now I'm happy to argue with you
about whether we should provide gender
affirming care to 12 children in the
fourth most populous state in the
country I'm happy to go to bad about
that but more fundamentally I don't know
about you but when I do some simple
math 3 to 12 is not an 1,00% increase
it's a 300% increase which is also it's
12 kids okay so for me this guy gets the
biggest red tufty I put him on the
plaque in the front of of the Hall of
shame because this is just lying and
this is trying to harm kids and if you
don't agree with me that's fine I'm I
I'll go to back to that later all right
so I'm gonna I'm going to wrap up here
with the last piece of the Hol of Shame
which is to take visualizations and to
just manipulate them and so I'm going to
draw on Sharpie
gate because Sharpie gate as we all know
is where you just take a sharpie marker
and you just you know you just draw on
some stuff right and you just take that
drawing and you just make up whatever
you want you just start drawing on
things and so you know Sharpie gate of
course was when Trump Drew on the map of
the hurricane right but I just want you
to know that this was not the first or
the only time that someone has taken a
graph and taken a Sharpie marker to it
okay it's not the first time I mean
Napoleon Napoleon tried to make clear
that his army wasn't so decimated in in
the war with Russia um Hillary Clinton
tried to undo or not undo but tried to
make the map look not so blue just by
taking a Sharpie marker to it um
Playfair tried to make the balance uh
the trade balance not looked so you know
so negative just by taking a Sharpie
marker to it and remember that one guy
in the snow map who actually died but he
wasn't near the Broad Street pump
because I don't know if you know this
story but the dude up there who died not
near the Broad Street pump he liked the
flavor of the water in the Broad Street
pump so he had his house servant go down
and get that water and that's how he got
collar and that's how he died his family
was like yeah there were a whole bunch
of people over here who died too so just
like the Sharpie marker you could just
do that so there are lots of ways to
distort the data and I would just
encourage you to be careful it is our
responsibilities people who are working
with data people who are visualizing
data is our responsibility in particular
to call out those that are misleading
that are lying and that are providing
disinformation to folks so QR code if
you want the slides and all the links
thank you so much uh enjoy the rest of
the rest of the
conference